thank you Yasser yes we are here with
the CEO of First Bank Hank party Cooper
Hank first of all welcome uh to the show
tell us a bit about this new partnership
between First Bank and the grandchester
and super bachelor's class yes thank you
thank you well I mean we this is the
second year that the first bank is um
is sponsoring this uh the grand Yes tour
and we're very pleased with this
um uh we we would like to to continue
and we see a lot of similarities between
business within banking actually and and
between yeah so we feel perfectly at
ease what is this what would you say
those main attributes are the
transferable ones between chess and
business in your opinion yes of course
well first of all you need to have a
strategy you need to have a plan in
business and also with jazz and you need
to take action you need to do something
then of course your opponent is also
acting so you need to adapt you need to
be flexible you need to understand how
to react to the movements of of your
opponent and in chess and in business
it's it's the same you need to be able
to sacrifice you need to invest
sometimes you need to give up something
in order to gain something something
else and of course the last thing but
certainly not the the least important
maybe the most important you want to win
and you want to win the game and you
want to win in business as well a lot of
similarities speaking of investment time
management is also something that you
invest whenever you think about a
specific move in chess does that apply
to business as well another one it's a
very valid one there is always the the
pressure of time time is money time is
scar so that you also need to take into
consideration yeah Hank thank you very
much for joining us now before I let you
go we have the world champion here we
have so many illustrious chess players
who is your favorite to win yes well
first of I would like to say that in
First Bank we did a tournament ourselves
and the winner of the First Bank
tournament was given a seat at the table
on Friday at the simultaneous
and our employee uh was actually the
only winner in the simultaneous so he
beat Mr casparov and he beat all the the
chess players it's a difficult question
so there is some Mr uh reports from from
Romania and there is also a Romanian
bank but there is also Mr Anish giri and
his Dutch and I was from the Netherlands
so I'm not yet sure who of the two but I
would say the two of them are my
favorites Anish and Richie definitely
solid picks correct Hank thank you very
much for joining thanks so much